bien vamos a seguir con estos problemas
del este y por cierto vamos en el
problema número 10 así que espero hoy
darle con todo e intentar hacer muchos
problemas de ese tema porque hoy es día
de gracias y la verdad es que tengo
muchas ganas de trabajar muy duro para
que así obtenga un gran apetito y en un
rato me vaya a comer ese pavo que me
está esperando allá abajo pero bueno voy
a hacer el problema número 10 y dice ah
o recuerda que estamos ya en las
preguntas abiertas dice cuál es el punto
medio entre las coordenadas 53 y 62 es
decir yo lo que quiero saber es cuál es
el punto medio entre 53 y 62 y bueno de
una manera muy sencilla cuando yo me
quiero tomar el punto medio lo que tengo
que hacer es tomarme el promedio de
estos dos es decir lo que voy a calcular
el 53
62 entre 2 y 4 es esto bueno esto es lo
mismo que aquí van 5 y 6 y 5 son 11
entonces 115 medios o lo que es lo mismo
esto es igual a 57.5 esta es una forma
de resolver este problema también te
puedes tomar una recta numérica y poner
ahí el punto medio sin embargo date
cuenta que aquí no hay ningún problema
no me sale un entero me sale algo con
punto decimal sin embargo esto es muy
fácil de ponerlo en la recta numérica
este problema si me deja tomar los
números racionales así que bueno vamos a
hacer el problema número 11 que me cabe
por aquí problema número 11 que por
cierto dice así un triángulo o un
triángulo tiene dos ángulos que tienen
la misma medida
dos ángulos que tienen la misma medida
si la medida de dos de sus lados es 50 y
30 cual es el menor valor posible para
el perímetro del triángulo así que
déjame hacerte aquí mi triángulo tengo
un triángulo más o menos así este se va
a ver más o menos así y aquí tengo esto
perfecto y ese triángulo tiene una
peculiaridad que este ángulo y este
ángulo miden lo mismo y lo padre de esto
es que si estos dos ángulos miden lo
mismo tú ya sabes por geometría que
entonces este lado y este lado miden lo
mismo entonces nos dice si la medida de
dos de sus lados es 50 y 30
cuál es el menor valor posible para el
perímetro del triángulo y date cuenta
que este lado puede medir 30 este 30 y
este 50 o el sudado caso este 50 está 50
y éste
y solamente tenemos estas dos posibles
formas de armar este triángulo con estos
datos que me dan este lado no podría ser
50 y este 30 por qué entonces no serán
lados iguales te das cuenta entonces
vamos a tomarnos las dos opciones la
opción de que esté en vida 30 éste me da
30 y este 50 que parece ser la opción
con más lógica que tenga el perímetro
menor porque en el otro caso si yo aquí
tengo el mismo triángulo sin embargo
ahora este lado mide 50 este lado mide
50 y este mide 30 estamos sumando 2
veces 50 mientras que aquí estamos
sumando solamente dos veces 30 por lo
tanto el perímetro más pequeño de estos
dos triángulos pues es este que es 30 30
más 50 lo cual es 110
este triángulo tiene como perímetro 110
y este otro triángulo que también es una
posible configuración tiene un perímetro
más grande así que ya está mi respuesta
es 110 y vamos a hacer el siguiente
problema entonces vamos a borrar la
pantalla el problema
número 12 que me dice y dice sí sí
sabemos que x cuadrada menos cuadrada
esto es igual a 77 y por otra parte
sabemos que x + gem esto es igual a 11
entonces lo que me preguntan es cuánto
vale x yo lo que quiero saber es cuánto
vale x y bueno hay varias formas de
resolver este problema tú podrías
despejar de aquí a equis meterla por acá
llegar a un sistema de ecuaciones que de
hecho llegaría es una ecuación
cuadrática pero hay una forma mucho más
fácil de realizar todo esto porque al
final aquí nos dan x + james y esto
dicen que es igual a 11 entonces
recordando cómo factorizar una
diferencia de cuadrados esto es lo mismo
que x más bien por x menos james estás
de acuerdo por x menos james esto es
igual a 77 actualizando esta expresión
llegamos a esto acabo de factorizar una
diferente
de cuadrados y ahora si yo sé que x más
yen es igual a 11 entonces me va a
quedar que 11 x x james esto es igual a
77 y de aquí puedo dividir ambos lados
de esta ecuación entre 11 y me va a
quedar que x - james esto es igual a 7
todavía no tengo el valor de x sin
embargo tengo esta ecuación de aquí y
por lo tanto ya va a ser muy fácil de
obtener el valor de x utilizando un
sistema de ecuaciones es decir que yo sé
que x + es igual a 11 y si ahora oh pero
estas dos ecuaciones que tengo aquí que
me va a quedar si yo la asumo me queda
que 2x éste y éste se van 2x es igual a
18 o dicho de otra manera x es igual a 9
y ya está hemos resuelto este problema
de una manera muy rápida y muy sencilla
así que volvemos la pantalla y vamos a
hacer el siguiente problema que es el
problema número 3 el problema número 13
que me dice
tamara cortará una pizza en pedazos de
forma de cuña es decir pedazos de la
forma original de la forma normal
como el que muestra la figura cada punta
de cada uno de los pedazos está en el
centro de la pizza y el ángulo de cada
pedazo es siempre mayor que 20 grados
pero menor que 30 grados y eso es una
muy interesante y ya me empieza a dar
hambre
cuál es uno de los posibles valores de
la cantidad de pedazos en los cuales se
puede partir esta pizza a ver vamos por
partes
yo tengo una pizza entonces vamos a
tomarnos una pizza de este color yo
tengo aquí mi pizza esta es mi pizza y
bueno esta pizza tiene un centro que va
a hacer este punto de kirk y además cada
uno de los pedazos se ve de la siguiente
forma aquí voy a tener uno de mis
pedazos llega hasta el centro y después
del centro para acá
está mi pedazo pero además yo sé que
este ángulo que por cierto vamos a
bautizarlo con el nombre detectan este
ángulo theta está entre 20 grados y 30
grados vamos a ponerlo aquí theta está
entre 20 grados y 30 grados y bueno
además nos dice que teta tiene que ser
mayor que 20 grados y menor que 30
grados eso es muy importante si yo lo
que quiero saber es cuál es uno de los
posibles valores de la cantidad de
pedazos en los cuales se puede dividir
esta pizza entonces imagínate que con
esta apertura vamos a hacer varios
pedazos y yo lo que quiero saber es
cuántos posibles pedazos podemos tener
bueno la primera forma que se me ocurre
de encontrar la solución es fijándonos
en los extremos qué pasaría si nosotros
tuviéramos un corte exacto de 20 grados
pues vamos a ponerlo aquí si cortamos
ésta también
de 20 grados el pedazo de pizza pues
entonces cuántos pedazos al día pues
esencialmente lo que hay que hacer es
dividir 360 grados que es toda la vuelta
de pizza entre 20 grados y esto me da
déjame ponerlo aquí 360 grados entre 20
grados y esto me da 18 dieciocho pedazos
salen pedazos salen cuando yo tengo un
ángulo de 20 grados ahora qué pasa si yo
tengo el otro ángulo el ángulo de 30
grados si yo tengo el ángulo de 30
grados cuántos pedazos saldrían bueno
pues van a salir 360 entre 30 pedazos y
cuántos eso pues esto es lo mismo que 12
pedazos
de datos
muy bien esto quiere decir que como no
puede ser 20 grados ni puede ser 30
grados
no puede ser 18 ni puede ser 12 pero
tiene que ser un número entre estos dos
antes que me apuntarlo la cantidad de
pedazos la cantidad de pedazos de esta
pizza que voy a cortar esta pizza está
entre 18 y entre 12 tiene que ser mayor
que 12 y menor que 18 me preguntan cuál
es uno de los posibles valores que puede
tomar la cantidad de pedazos en los
cuales se puede partir esta pizza bueno
pues hay muchas respuestas podría ser 13
podría ser 14 pedazos podría ser 15
pedazos
podría ser 16 pedazos puede hacer 17
pedazos todos estos son valores posibles
de pedazos que estén entre 12 y 18
pedazos por lo tanto todas estas son
respuestas correctas
nos piden una pues podremos poner
cualquiera de estas y de hecho se me
ocurre la de enmedio que es 15 y tal vez
esta corresponde a 25 grados
tendrá que calcularlo no importa lo que
sé es que cualquiera de estas respuestas
es correcta y muchas veces esto es lo
que nos causa un problema y tal vez nos
haga equivocarnos si solamente me piden
una de estas posibles respuestas pues
damos una y ya está así que vámonos el
siguiente problema un problema que
espero que no tengan que ver con comida
porque ya me dio hambre problema número
14 y tenemos una sucesión la sucesión y
después le sigue 3a
después puntitos y yo
perdón es que vengo de un lugar llamado
colina windy y allá estaba helando
espero no enfermarme a que se decía una
sucesión a 3 am y así puntitos y después
dice el primer número de esta serie es
ah bueno aquí está y todos los demás
términos son tres veces el término
anterior son tres veces el término
anterior si la suma de los primeros
cinco términos es 605 cuánto vale a lo
que queremos saber es el valor de amd y
bueno para esto vamos a ver quiénes son
los primeros cinco términos el primer
término es el segundo término es 3a
estoy multiplicando por tres al término
anterior y se multiplicó por 3 a 3
me da 9
y multiplicando por tres a 927
y si multiplicó por tres 27m 281
es decir que aquí tengo uno dos tres
cuatro o cinco términos y nosotros lo
que queremos es tomarnos la suma de
estos cinco términos y cuánto es la suma
de todos estos pues vamos a ver a uno
más tres son 44 más 9 49 es 13 13 más 27
es lo mismo que 40 40 más 81 es 121 121
y además yo sé que este 121 am que es la
suma de los primeros cinco términos me
dicen que esto es lo mismo que 605 y
ahora vamos a despejar para obtener el
valor de amd va a ser igual a 605 entre
121 y cuantos esto
cabe haber vamos a serlo 605 lo voy a
dividir entre 121 y cabe como seis veces
cabe como cinco veces haber cinco por
unas cinco y llevamos nada 5 por 2 10 y
llevamos 15 por 15 y 16 perfecto 605
entonces la resta me da 0 y a vale 5
perfecto ya que tengo la respuesta de
este problema el problema número 14 y ya
no me da tiempo de hacer otro así que
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo